[Music]
in hard times news submitted by Diet
Pringles does that exist the other
called in an elf fries what's caught
it's like reduced fat right within a no
yeah that's right they're not buyers are
delicious bird I like I like healthy
junk food it's it's like the funniest
like contradicting thing that's yeah I
had these fried okras the other day and
they were like a Trader Joe's they have
them in there like I think they're
dehydrated okras whatever it was it was
it's always like reduced fat which just
means it's 30 calories less than the
other one yeah it's like coming you're
still good sugar yeah that's another way
to or they just make it a smaller wafer
or whatever the [ __ ] you're eating what
are you shoving in your mouth junk is
junk yo a Navy veteran with terminal
cancer had to raise money with the yard
sales to plan for his own funeral so he
knew he was gonna die he has terminal
cancer
okay this is someone who's like a
hardworking person till the day he died
that is very respectable my family to
have to pay for this I don't know what
that feels like to know when they the
exact moment you're gonna die or roughly
about it's like two weeks and then you
have to sit with that maybe he wanted to
throw the sickest funeral ever
and he's like wait the government gives
me this much he's like that's not gonna
be enough
I need the sickest all gonna be based
around food bill first year the sickest
thing that keeps him on the regular one
has to be amazing yeah fireworks galore
that's it yeah so his name is Willie
he's 66 years old he may be better
Willie they don't name people and I
really know it's funny women um oh
people look so cute and like harmless
but you know they've been through some
[ __ ] he looks like enough that's why
they're harmless now when he was in the
Navy happiest navy boot ever yeah he was
in the Navy from 70 to 76 during the
Vietnam War there were these two guys
named David and Edie
who stopped by his yard sale
Vania and they asked like Oh like I just
struck up conversation so then that's
when Willie was like oh you know what
spread the word that I'm having the yard
sale because I'm trying to save up money
for a funeral and they were like oh
really it was funerals of mine and then
they were like oh my god you know I'm so
skeptical of people though like if they
said that to me I'll be like good
scammed dude if they said that to me if
I still didn't like the stuff I'd be
like I just don't see anything on one
I'm sorry cuz when I hear that [ __ ] you
I go like you're a mean to your kids huh
that's what I think they won't pay for
your funeral yep you were mean to your
kids to this guy with a car like you
were mean to your military yeah I don't
know man like it's it's hard for me to
have sympathy right off the bat I'm
always I think there's just so much
shady people and this yeah there's Sony
manipulative people that's and I've
fallen for it many so huh yeah so then
you're like I'm not gonna do this again
[ __ ] even if they are being
genuine yeah yeah it's cuz there's been
so many more shady people than genuine
people yeah so how does not even tell
you this though cuz if they tell you
you're not gonna feel bad for them if
they don't tell you you won't know
that's true he's not gonna care about
the never well I mean I feel like if I
could feel them maybe it'd be different
you know what it is man like I always
like to say to myself that I'm more
skeptic but I think I'm it really highly
depends on my mood right so if I'm in a
good mood in a turtle
it'll happen like there's just dude
outside of the fight Jim last time I got
really pissed because I was like he was
like you don't manage trying to get sell
so yeah I'll buy you sandwich because I
want a [ __ ] sandwich I was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] ask you for a sandwich and
he didn't say I don't want a sandwich he
said I don't want a [ __ ] sandwich it
made me mad but so they did like a
couple days ago on Monday and he was
like excuse me sir $10 it's like good
and he cursed me out like a couple weeks
ago laugh is like it's just the mood I'm
in I forgot so that makes me laugh I
usually go for a more okay if that guy's
like aziza can I get a sandwich now Mike
and then I'm like sure whatever
I'll buy you a sandwich and then he's
like I don't want a [ __ ] sandwich and
I laugh I'm like yeah yeah that's pretty
good
it's like the audacity of that I feel
like if if it's like not on the words
it's on the person like so if I'm at the
garage sale and I'm like oh this person
feels like a good person then even if
they're not a good person
I don't care they made me feel like they
were a good person but bad people are
very good at Manuka that's true but I
feel like I've been around enough bad
people that I can kind of tell the
difference between fake bad people I
think canvas sometimes we still get
duped man you just catch on faster now
can you imagine being in his yard sale
be like how much then what happened he's
like 30 and you're like I'll give you
eight bucks okay what oh you got a die
anyway do you need is what year to use
this lamp won't you give it to someone
who can actually use it for a long time
good point
can I take the bulb it's a two-year bulb
we know you're not gonna need that okay
all I see it is like you're being greedy
buddy so the days that pass by get
discounted it's like 9 bucks
eight bucks seven bucks it's like a
alway job you still have to be real
grocery shopping yesterday at a Korean
market and there's this older Korean
guide that was selling like kimchi that
they made and then Barrow was thinking
in her mind like oh I've kind of felt
bad for them I was thinking that at all
I was like better [ __ ] taste good if
I'm gonna buy this [ __ ] hopefully bad I
was like oh it's good I'll buy it I
bought it cause it tastes good but if it
did nothing like your this is how this
is how [ __ ] cold I am but I'm not
that cold okay but in the first so so so
my parents they can't get a house in in
Japan because like after a certain age
well I don't know if it's the same here
but you can't get like mortgages and
stuff like that because they go oh
you're gonna die anyway right yeah and
I'm like duh I was like that's your
fault you should have [ __ ] saved up
and I'm like how much you need I'll get
it for you I'll get it
but then my initial reaction in my heart
is like aren't you supposed to be the
possible one with money about me and
then I don't know and then I after I
lecture them then I go I'll do it I'll
do it
you said your finger wag first yeah you
gotta do it I gotta get out my sister
you're so much like my dad that's what
you would do I'd be like hey Dad
20 bucks it's like why don't you plan
ahead you got a plan but your dad that's
okay you know imagine you doing that to
your dad like doesn't that make you go
like what the [ __ ] yeah like this is why
we didn't have a house growing up it's
just funny yeah do you remember all
those people that gave all our stuff
away quit because they thought out the
apocalypse was coming and like it was
gonna be the end of the world 2012 yeah
yeah the thought was gonna be the end of
the world so they like we're given
getting rid of all their stuff because
I'm not gonna need it like you're a
sinner take my dog like that is so funny
dude he's like so religiously confident
cuz a pastor everyone's like freaking
about y2k he goes think about that one
in 2011 the one in 2012 well that was
like a call in and believe in that [ __ ]
either
twelve was because of the mind that guys
at mania because my dad specifically
said I guess like biblically speaking he
goes you can't there's no way you could
predict the end of the world it's just
gonna happen you're not gonna prepare
now there's signs like sparrows dying
unless we got some [ __ ] locusts and
that [ __ ] centaur comes from the sky
or whatever then I'm not saying [ __ ] do
you know I see a centaur with hell wings
and yeah I'm like yeah I think that's
the locusts destroy billions of dollars
of crops I want to see [ __ ] was that
Cerberus that [ __ ] dog come out hell
yeah
if a [ __ ] centaur with wings come
down I'll be like what kind of scam you
playing for you will suck Satan's dick
in hell
zip but boy was it was a scam already
sucks aids day yeah we were not good guy
and even get paid for e all right Willie
he doesn't have children he has three
sisters but they're not financially able
to help and so he doesn't want to have
them be stuck with his funeral bills he
says he wants to have a viewing in
Pennsylvania for his friends and then
she wants to be buried next to his
parents in Virginia so his VA benefits
they don't cover the cost of transport
transferring the body to Virginia so
then that's when he started doing these
yard sales and then when those two dudes
found out about it they created a go
Club now they have sixty one thousand
whoa oh that's really hanging that all
the money that they're they're raising
past the funeral expenses that they want
to donate to another veterans within me
what if he doesn't actually die in two
weeks
I mean how they just gonna take the
money be like in two weeks who said two
weeks Oh wasn't it like I'm gonna
terminal cancer oh you're more
pessimistic at all he probably did yes
Stage four cancers so he's kind of like
starting a foundation for people that
can't fund their funerals okay a
foundation I got a no this is him when
the guy that helped them start the
GoFundMe oh boy
they look relay yeah they look like moon
or whatever it could be as kid I wonder
how much money is getting laundered
through GoFundMe oh yeah everything has
a thing and you can create a story from
anything mm-hmm
and then you could just like filter a
ton of cash to it and give it to a
single entity or individual let's do it
you could even um like create a story
and take pictures for it like I'm pretty
sure there's like a red tape process
that you have to go oh they can't come
from one person but it could come from
many people right but but even then you
can make a budget count you can
a ton of accounts those stories where
people have gotten caught from money
laundering or money porno for doing fake
GoFundMe [ __ ] yeah
portal huh then how much money is
getting watered to there that's what I
want I mean the cool thing is you know
the thing about laundering money through
GoFundMe is if you're a popular page
you'll you'll end up making more money
because people might actually like buy
into your story yeah they have like a
trending now thing else on weeds Thank
You Tube like they're pushing her your
buzz oh people actually care about it
and then they start putting what do you
do it that's dope that's good
[Music]